Christmas is one of my favorite spooky
Seasons stick with me here let's face it
Santa himself is a little creepy but
there are many more U tied monsters like
the uads sons of the troll grla who keep
busy in the 13 Days leading up to
Christmas by giving gifts and causing
General Mayhem they're kind of a big
deal in Iceland also a big deal my
favorite murder floof the ulat oh and
the mischievous Alpine Spirits perched
in who fly around the night sky in the
wild Hunt yeah they helped Inspire the
famous crompus our dear oldt an Santa
who has a fondness for brutal whippings
then there's the Christmas witch or fra
Pera also known as labana don't want to
put out a nice meal or some cookies
during the 12 Days of Christmas she'll
slit your stomach open and replace your
intestines with trash way worse than a
lump of coal